whether you're local or just visiting
you can always find plenty of family fun
at circus circus free shows coming back
full time rocky thea stopped by to get
all the details
welcome to circus circus you all know
and love this place and
we've got great news a full release our
full release schedule
of circus show acts are back and
obviously jeff this was a little
different
during the pandemic right yeah
absolutely we're excited to finally go
back to our full schedule
when we shut down we opened up with a
limited schedule we had to go to even a
more reduced schedule
after the roll back in november and it
was tough because we know we got some
great talent here that we can't share
with the public as much as we want
so we're really excited that we're
coming up into the end of this month
we're going to be going through and
start
doing our full schedules we've got our
trapeze we'll have two different trapeze
acts that are going to be coming here
we have some amazing jugglers
some hand balancing groups and some
great aerialists that will be coming
so we do these shows every hour on the
half hour starting at 11
30 here and that will happen in the
starting around memorial day
example there's no shortage of
entertainment you are the director of
entertainment here at circuit circus
so how does it feel for you guys to have
this back this is such a gym
you know for the community and for
tourists as well oh it's been great
especially because you can see what it
does it draws the crowds in
we've been waiting for the crowds to
come we've been so excited that both
here and up in the adventure dome
it's just been fantastic having new
groups of people coming in to experience
things that they've been missing for the
last year so who can enjoy this
obviously the kids but i think the
adults might like it too
oh absolutely i think the adults love
this more than the kids
they go man i wish i could do that and
so it's really fun to see an adult
experience this even it's their first
time that's when it's really fun
to go this is something that i don't get
to see every day and it's here
free at circa circus free we love the
sound of that
we love this one what else can other can
people enjoy here at circuit circuits
let's just go down the lid well we're
standing right in the middle of the most
iconic midway in the world they've got
all the games the midway games
here up in the midway and then back in
the adventure dome we have the full
theme park in the adventure dome that's
open daily
so there's a lot of stuff that they can
do here just for the family
and lastly here where can people go to
reserve or get tickets or what how does
that work
so for tickets for the attention home
you can go to adventuredome.com and be
able to purchase your tickets there
you can always walk right up we don't
require reservations to come to the
adventure build
so come on down and then of course here
for the midway axe you don't need a
ticket just come on down
it's free to see this all day long love
that come on down in classic circus
terminology right come on down everybody
here at circuit circus i will send it
back to you i think i'm gonna go
get on stage because i don't know i want
to try that out what do you think
i think you'd be great at this